Britney Spears Paris Hilton now Pamela
Anderson women getting to tell their own
stories tearing apart the ones written
about them is my favorite Trend right
now honestly I wanted to know all about
this documentary the second I saw it and
I've seen a lot of celebrity
documentaries Amy about Amy Winehouse
might be my favorite but there aren't a
ton that go as far as Pamela a love
story the revelations trauma and even
tender moments are all so real that at
times I felt a little uncomfortable
getting that close to her life I just
needed to know why she would subject
herself to that for Anderson this is
just her moral philosophy she vows to be
vulnerable in all aspects of her life
it's the only way to live life
vulnerable and this was possibly the
culmination of an entire life of Pam
just going as hard as possible not that
she doesn't have some lines The
Producers really wanted her to be
involved behind the scenes but she
refused she knew that she'd be too
tempted to edit herself and honestly
relatable that's also why it's not her
voice reading the journal entries I'm
glad I got this diary it should really
help
maybe I'll write a book one day she
would have been like nope not saying
that not saying that not saying that and
five minutes later the documentary is
over
given us your journals are you open to
reading them in the film I don't know if
I want to go there and read them so what
really struck me about the scenes with
Pamela Anderson was how natural it felt
actually like I seriously thought I was
just sitting with her having a
conversation about her life and that was
no accident that was the whole idea like
she was staying at her grandmother's old
home in Canada and there was no reason
to film it anywhere else when it came
time to actually film the documentary
Pamela was as down to earth as you'd
imagine she didn't want to do any of
that Hollywood nonsense you know Pam she
wanted to keep it as raw as possible
this is the woman who still dyes her own
hair from boxes she gets at the
drugstore BTW she had no interest in
letting other people do her makeup in
her own home she was gonna do it herself
so if you've seen it you know now pretty
much what it's like to hang out with Pam
and to think the documentary almost
didn't happen so as we've covered I love
celebrity documentary series but not
everybody feels the same way I think
it's hilarious that one guy who really
hates this genre is the very same
director of Pamela a love story Ryan
White like he'd normally work on movies
about highbrow subjects like the
overturning of Prop 8 in California or
like the life of Frida Kelly the
secretary for the Beatles so a
documentary about a girl from Baywatch
and Home Improvement was about the last
thing he wanted to do enter Brandon
Thomas Lee who definitely has his mom's
level of Charisma now he wanted to
produce a movie about his mom and Ryan
White was the guy he wanted to take the
job Ryan assumed that Pamela was a
low-class self-obsessed Hollywood dits
but my girl Pam showed him that she was
actually A Soulful intelligent woman she
loved talking to him about his career
and about life in general what she
wasn't interested in talking about was
herself and that's what sealed the deal
for him to take the directing gig though
she would not not let him call her
Pamela it's Mom or nothing pal no matter
how big you get if I were Pamela
Anderson I would have been shaken like
crazy right before this Premiere but I'm
not quite as tough as she is so Vogue
followed Anderson around getting ready
with her sons and they all really opened
up joking around with each other and
showing us another glimpse of their
beautiful relationship actually watching
it yeah totally different experience God
I'm scared it's not making a help
as you can imagine it was hard for
Pamela to relive a lot of the traumas in
her life but it was much harder to see
her sons see it I would just start
crying and like never stop until the
credits rolled and while that was hard
what she really loved about the
experience was getting to see some of
her whole movies with her kids she
hadn't seen them since the pair were
just like tiny I mean no one ever
watches through all their home movies
years later like who even has them
anymore am I right though there's one
family member from those days that we
haven't heard from so like my other big
cue after this was what Tommy Lee
thought of the whole thing you know how
Sylvester Stallone and Tim Allen made a
big deal about how much they rejected
Pamela Anderson's stories about them I
remember talking to Sylvester Stallone
one time and he offered me a condo and
of course to be his number one girl and
I was like does that mean there's number
two well you wouldn't expect Tommy Lee
to be the mature one but plot twist he
is he's on team Pamela when it comes to
her telling her story on her terms don't
count on him to give a review though
he's moved on now and has no interest in
watching it himself though considering
how successful their story has been for
Hulu and Netflix I kinda think he's
waiting for someone to offer him enough
green for a Tommy Lee documentary but
honestly I just want to talk about all
those tattoos he's got like it's not
quite a lifetime of handwritten journals
but you gotta admit they're pretty
memorable
okay so like Pamela Anderson can we be
best friends now you are actually a lot
cooler than I thought